Olá
[Aplausos]
eu sou Amanda Oliveira e nas em uma
favela na zona sul de São Paulo eu
cresci vendo minha mãe fazer uma
refeição para que eu e minhas irmãs
pudéssemos fazer duas viagens gente
levar tudo de dentro do barraco onde
morávamos papo efeito de papelão ou em
madeira quando eu tinha 3 meses de vida
eu adorei sim tem muito gripada sem
acontecer financeiros minha mãe
improvisou uma inalação serviu a água
colocou em uma bacia e pediu para ti meu
pai me segurasse com o rosto virado para
a fumaça que subia ela sempre fazer isso
com as minhas irmãs mas naquela noite o
meu pai cochilou e eu caí com o rosto
dentro da água fervendo conta a minha
mãe que ela não sabia onde estava o meu
nariz a minha boca e os meus olhos até
que tinha derretido encolhido Eu tive
três parar e acreditem 22 dias internado
e os médicos começaram a preparar a
minha família para mim a morte Mas a
vida na favela é dura É verdade falta
muita coisa mas não falta a fé então 80
mulheres resolveram se unir na porta do
barraco onde morávamos e cada uma dentro
de suas crenças fizeram seus pedidos
preces e orações porque eu sobrevivesse
não é que a vida me deu uma segunda
chance olha eu aqui eu estou desperta e
sei que a minha passagem aqui na terra a
traz consigo a força de um grande
desafio e na ativar a sentença injusta
que persegue a vida dos mais pobres
sobretudo confrontar os abusos que não
fazem valer as leis dos direitos humanos
e traz à tona uma grande a questão
criança pobre também tem o direito de
ser criança
vamos lá eu vou direto ao ponto eu nasci
na favela não sei favelada mas nascer a
segunda um lugar para se fazer grandes
coisas e me questiono diariamente Porque
será que alguns seres humanos ainda não
compreenderam isso
e Até 1950 mulheres como eram convidados
para participarem de reuniões apenas
para redigirem atas não tinham vez nem
voz e olha eu aqui mulher fazer lada no
palco a voltar ainda é grande mas parece
que muita coisa já mudou de lá para cá
não a mesma nós estamos ocupando e agora
que eu estou aqui eu quero usar a minha
sensibilidade materna no meu feminino
para falar sobre as crianças faveladas
tô sempre foi uma menina cheia de sonhos
O maior deles era voar talvez por isso
eu prefiro a ver pássaros voando do que
engaiolados
e as quatro anos de idade eu coloquei
uma toalhinha nas costas e pulei da
carteira da Escola Objetivo Claro era
voar mas fui direto com a cara no chão
12 pontos na testa e Esse Galo aqui e
uma grande mensagem minha fase adulta
ela não é tão simples assim Amanda Ainda
mais quando se nasce pobre mas é
possível que eu comecei a ascender
socialmente ainda na infância quando me
encontrei com tem um Gol mágico na sala
de aula de um projeto e social mas deixa
eu explicar melhor essa história de
tambor mágico
ainda na infância minha mãe mudou-se
para o interior de São Paulo para tentar
uma vida melhor para mim para as minhas
irmãs e logo nós percebemos que
estávamos morando em um bairro dominado
pelo tráfico de drogas e pelo alto
índice de exploração sexual infantil
a pergunta alternativa aí com medo a
minha mãe matriculou a mim e as minhas
irmãs neste projeto social
o e lá encontrei uma professora de
música chamada Valquíria e eu vim minha
vida a começar a mudar gradativamente
quando comecei a participar desse grupo
musical composto por crianças que
tocavam tambor era um grupo chamado
batuca Lapa logo no primeiro dia eu
aprendi um ritmo que eu nunca esqueci
esse aqui ó
era o início de uma nova história eu
senti um som grave do tambor e quo
aquela parte da minha área familiar
e logo eu percebi que era igual a força
da batida do meu coração
fazer parte de um grupo musical em uma
comunidade dominada pela desigualdade
social começou a mexer com a minha
imaginação me abriu novos mundos e novas
possibilidades e na medida em que eu me
tornava a protagonista da minha própria
história e eu sentia que as minhas asas
cresciam meu tambor esse aqui me ligou
para grandes palcos grandes campeonatos
viveu voz e visibilidade e foi correndo
essa jornada inesperada aconteceu aos 19
anos eu também consciência de que outras
meninas que vinham da mesma realidade
que a minha também tinha o direito de
sonhar ocupar e realizar eu não queria
que ficasse só em mim esse projeto
social fez pela minha vida é semelhante
a maneira como você reage ao ver uma
estrela cadente no céu fez mágica foi aí
então que eu saquei que minha vida tinha
sido transformada por meio da música e
da arte que vinha da sala de aula deste
projeto social então vive mulher
musicista a empreendedora social e disse
para mim mesma eu vou multiplicar o
impacto um de As Valquírias uma
organização social que é uma
distribuidor a cidade para meninas
mulheres e seus filhos e trabalha duro
para que muito em breve o tema
desigualdade de gênero e social seja
visto somente nos livros de história
certa vez ainda foi correndo esse
caminho uma criança de classe média-alta
me contou sobre a sua incrível
experiência de viver os sonhos Disney e
eu enquanto ela me contava a minha
criança interior vibrava
Afinal todos nós adultos um dia fomos
crianças e provavelmente em algum
momento de nossas vidas desejamos
acessar a magia desse sonho eu acho que
mais do que um lugar fascinante a
experiência mágica que a Disney proporci
ona podem tornar qualquer criança um
adulto bem sucedido sim é real
experiências positivas fazem alunos a
entrar pela ferida em forma um adultos
bem-sucedidos foi assim quando eu entrei
no a primeira vez foi assim quando eu
toquei o meu tambor pela primeira vez
foi assim quando eu assisti uma peça de
teatro de rua pela primeira vez
oi lá
é uma coisa nós precisamos dizer acessar
experiências mágicas parece ter um Sonho
Distante para as crianças que vieram da
mesma realidade que a minha estranho não
é a história dessas crianças em um conto
de fadas não caberia e eu fico de cara
Tô fazendo uma reflexão aqui a pirâmide
de Maslow ela define cinco categorias de
necessidades humanas
fisiológicas segurança afeto estima e
por último a auto-realização que quando
se trata de alguém que nasceu na favela
eu chamo essa auto-realização de
ascender socialmente
e eu posso garantir que quase cem
porcento das pessoas que moram em favela
ainda estão na base dessa pirâmide ainda
não tem garantia diária de alimentação
água ou segurança é que eu quero dizer
com isso é que uma das formas de
rompermos com esse ciclo de pobreza e
levar milhões de pessoas para o topo
dessa pirâmide Esse é um aliado dos
sonhadores criativos visionários
alucinados por inovação e pela arte
esperançosa os ousados da
mas nós temos que sonhar nós temos que
acreditar que o campo da auto-realização
é para todos para o branco e para o
preto Ele nasceu rico e falando que
nasceu o quadro também toda criança tem
uma asa nas costas rica uma podre também
acontece aqui a rica tem asas e com seus
recursos e acessos conseguem usá-las
para voar é só pobre ela tem asas mas a
pobreza é uma gaiola e quando essa
criança pobre vai bater suas asas para
voar ela percebe que está aprisionada
pela falta de acesso ela quer fazer
natação não pode ela sonhar em fazer
aula de música não pode ela quer ir na
piscina de bolinha mas também não pode
são privadas de todos os direitos
básicos as vezes que a comer Nem sempre
tende a dormir mas às vezes o frio não
deixa aqui a sonhar mas a madrugada é
barulhenta demais pow pow pow pow bom
E é assim que chega o som do tiro na
madrugada
lá se foi o sonho mais um corpo
estendido no chão
e Parem de matar os nossos pais e os
nossos irmãos
chega eu quero democratizar o acesso a
grandes coisas e coisas positivas e
extraordinárias eu quero tirar essas
crianças da base da pirâmide para que
não seja necessário punir um as em sua
fase adulta eu quero preencher a vida
das Crianças faveladas assim como eu de
experiências e não de coisas eu quero
que elas têm hoje histórias boas para
contar e não coisas para mostrar
é porque você explica com uma criança
pobre que em pleno século 21 ela não
pode acessar o seu Face porque ela
nasceu pobre financeiramente
não queremos mais explicar nada queremos
resolver queremos democratizar até
porque existe consequências colaterais
para o adulto que não pode ser criança
isso que eu estou falando aqui para
vocês não contém madrugada fora acordada
pensando como é que eu vou resolver o
problema dessas crianças problema é esse
que um dia foi a causa da minha maior
dor
nós estamos criando a justiça sai aqui
naturalmente entreguei que se nasceu
pobre não realizará o seu trânsito Ah
mas se você nasceu rico bem vindo Você
vai chegar lá quando eu e todo time do
Instituto As Valquírias estamos na
favela as crianças vem ao nosso encontro
nos contar sobre os seus sonhos elas
fazem como eu fazia com minhas
professoras de projeto social é porque
encontram em nós o fio de esperança para
chegar lá e nos somos esse fim de
esperança eu tenho para mim que quando
uma pessoa enxerga o problema essa mesma
pessoa tem a solução e eu estou atenza e
disposta a resolver esse problema que eu
enxerguei e aperta as crianças de papel
de todo o Brasil a falta de acesso a
sonho e realização
podem contar com suas asas as crianças
das favelas brasileiras agora podem
contar com essa energia que pulsa aqui
dentro e vai democratizar o acesso à
igualdade de sonhar e realizar e quando
finalmente
democratizar o acesso ao direito dos
mais pobres de também sonhar e realizar
eu nunca jamais vou esquecer de que essa
história começou com o som grave de um
tambor nas mãos de uma menina favelada
prazer eu sou a favelada e para que esse
mundo se torne mais justo democrático e
igualitário
precisamos com urgência
compreender que a Malásia acontecerá
quando todos acessarem esse direito de
sonhar e realizar e para que isso
aconteça Vamos com a força da igualdade
social infantil E de gênero tirar da
gaiola as crianças que nasceram com asas
para voar
juntos a mágica acontece e a igualdade
social a panela
E aí